[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's that time of the month again so
only have revealed the six no the seven
free games we'll be getting as part of
PlayStation Plus for the month of July
2017 this time we have three games for
the ps4 two for the PlayStation 3 and
two for the Vita as well all of which
can be downloaded on Tuesday the fourth
of July oh and like usual one of the
beta games is available on your ps4 this
month we have a party title a horror
game an interactive story and a 2d
fighter amongst others let's start with
the offerings on the ps4 first stop is
until dawn this is a survival horror
title in which you will see so much
blood you'll probably throw up you will
be making the decisions for eight high
school teenagers who have decided to
spend the weekend at an isolated Lodge
what could go wrong you may ask well
everything bloody everything goes wrong
thinks viral into chaos mirroring great
horror films like Friday the 13th and
the sauce series this is absolutely
brilliant and deserves your time
Metacritic has this one at 80% so you
need to try it if you haven't already
next up is the season pass for Game of
Thrones yet another telltale narrative
adventure in this one you'll be taking
charge of a host of characters who have
to stand up against Ramsay snow cater to
the whims of Margaery and find a way to
prepare for winter if that makes no
sense at all and you probably don't like
the TV series Game of Thrones but those
that do will appreciate the way the
story ties into the Canon it's sadly not
in the same league as The Walking Dead
tie-ins but a solid game nonetheless oh
and probably the easiest platinum you
will ever receive Metacritic 64% if
you've been paying attention during e3
you'll already know the next game on the
list for the month that's you it's a
party game which you play with your
mobile phone or tablet using Sony's new
play link technology it's kind of like
buzz quiz in which you answer questions
but those questions are designed to make
you laugh at one another and interact
with your friends in the same room
there's over a thousand questions so
don't expect duplicates right away the
game will also use your phone's camera
and
our artistic skills definitely not one
for the hardcore players but a brilliant
introduction to party gaming for up to
six players that's you is
brand-spanking-new so no reviews
available at the moment please give me
your thoughts once you've had a go this
one will be available to download up
until October the 24th do me a favor if
you find this video useful please give a
like even if you hate all the games on
the list please keep in mind I'm only
reporting back on what the PS Plus games
are and the down vault really hurts the
channel anyway that's enough of that
over to the ps3 first up is Tokyo jungle
which is a survival action game during
story mode you will complete missions as
different animals in order to find out
where the heck are the humans of God
ever wanted to be a Pomeranian dog a
beagle hyena or maybe a lion well
they're all here in this survival
adventure there's a local co-op element
too if you want to see how long you can
survive together it's a very hard game
to sell but Eurogamer and giantbomb both
gave this one close to top marks 9 out
of 10 and 4 out of 5 respectively
Eurogamer even went as far as calling
this GTA with animals worth a try what
do you think please let me know game
number five is Darkstalkers resurrection
which is a one-on-one fighting game on a
2d plane playing similarly to early
Street Fighter or King of Fighters games
this one is trying to bring back retro
fighting to the masses released back in
2013 so keep that in mind but it did
achieve solid eights across the board
from all the major news outlets finally
over to the Vita for two further titles
the first one don't die mister robot is
available on your ps4 too this is an
arcade minigame extravaganza cigar
chasing or last-second dodging this one
isn't trying to blow your mind but it
has the power to be infuriatingly
addictive it doesn't do much but what it
does it does well metacritic 76 out of
100 and game number 7 for the month is
elemental or maybe elements forel you
must be Elemental right if you like loco
loco this is the pick for you
beautifully crafted awesome soundtrack
and just a pleasure to play this isn't
the run-of-the-mill platformer and many
we'll give up on it a little too early
before they get to grips but when you do
this really is a joy so that is it seven
titles for the month I'm looking forward
to until dawn and that's you if I
actually had any friends to play with oh
and I'll be grabbing elemental for my
Vita too anyway my opinions don't matter
what are you guys going to grab I'm Adam
from Playstation grenades as always it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]